We live in Southwest Florida,
and late last night, early this morning,
we started getting the outer,
dirty bands of Hurricane Helene.
And with those outer bands comes thunderstorms and tornadoes.
And unfortunately, this morning,
a tornado touched down on our property
where we have our construction office.
And we have a ton of property damage
and damage to our equipment and trucks and our building.
So, honestly,
we're not expecting this after Hurricane Ian.
Like, the property was okay,
but this is a totally different story.
So I am on my way over there now to help with cleanup
and just take pictures and assess all the damage.
So, yeah.
So, long day of cleanup ahead of us.